hello everyone and welcome to the grand
final of the magnus crossing chess tour
it's uh daniel duba versus hikaru
nakamura a lot of you have already
requested this game this is the first
game of their match
and a few words about the at the
tournament so this is like i said the
grand final the
end of the magnus crossing chess tour
and we have magnus carlsen ding liren
daniel dubois and hikaru nakamura
uh daniel dubois and magnus carlsen
qualified by winning at least
one of the tour events uh okay magnus
won three out of four double
but hikaru and ding qualified by being
well the best participants who have not
won an event because magnus simply won
two too many events for everyone to win
at least one event
and uh this is a like i said the first
game the prize fund is 300 000
and it's a bit different now it's going
to last a little longer so they will be
playing
five sets uh in the semi-finals uh every
set will is consisted of four rapid
games uh
and then for the finals uh it's the best
of seven sets uh and every set again uh
consisted of four rapid games so quite
interesting and it's going to take quite
a while to uh
to see who emerges victorious in the end
so without further ado let's check it
out already an incredible game
uh uh dooba wit the white pieces opens
with
d4 nakamura goes knight to f6 with c4
e6 and now knight to c3 inviting
nakamura to go for the
uh nimzo indian defense which he does
nakamura says he's ready to fight
we have knight to f3 and now uh nakamura
just castles we have bishop to g5
uh pinning the knight here and the now
c5 striking in the center so this is all
well known territory
uh rook to c1 and h6 now they're
checking if uh
adobo will capture maybe go back maybe
go to h4 so here he goes to h4
and only now c captures on d4 we have
knight captures and
d5 and this is all perfectly fine
everything has been played before
all standard nimzo stuff we have c
captures and d5 and now of course uh you
cannot recapture
uh so first g5 or you could eliminate
one of the defenders and then recapture
but nakamura goes g5 first
bishop to g3 and now it's a very
interesting moment because this position
has been reached some
20 times in top level play and every
time queen captures on d5 was played
which is fine you develop the queen to
an eye central square the knight is
pinned so of course the knight cannot
capture but here
nakamura played knight captures on the
e5 and it is
as of move 10 that we have a completely
new game
so let's see uh let's see what happens
after knight captures on d5 we have
e3 by duboff and now queen to a5 a
perfectly normal developing move uh
or or is it yeah because you are
attacking the knight three times now
it's
and it seems like white should
definitely do something about this but
duboff says
uh nope just uh bishop to d3 you you are
more than welcome to capture on c3
and here a lot of possibilities are
possible for example if you go for
knight captures on c3 you attack the
queen bee captures in check
the king will move and now you have uh
want some material here but the problem
is
uh you you're uh well the queen said is
completely undeveloped
the rook is still on f8 white is ready
to bust open the position with h4 f4
the queen has a very easy entrance to
the game uh
and it's just uh just a very tough
position
to play for black it is in fact a losing
position for black
so here we might see something like
bishop captures e captures and
black might start developing pieces but
now we would see something like rook c5
attacks the queen
queen has to move and now bishop d6 and
it's just uh
the beautiful bishop perry is here the
rook is coming into the game queen is
coming still to h5
h4 is coming and it's a very just a very
natural game to be playing with white so
here instead after this bishop to d3
move
uh we could also go for bishop
characters instead of knight capture
this comes with check so it's a bit more
forcing and if
black wants to play a bit more uh
reserved well let's say knight back to
f6 but then
white breaks open with f4 and now after
captures captures it's still
a whole lot of pressure black will have
to suffer you can even castle play rook
f3 rook here
go for the king it's just very easy to
play this one thing you could do after
this bishop to d3 is
e5 and this is in fact the best
thing you can do you just attack this
knight point is uh if you go for
something like
uh bishop captures then we would see
knight captures on c3 first with an
attack on the queen and also
uh exposing the attack onto this bishop
so here after e5
we would see knight b3 and then captures
let's say characters b
and the queen goes back guarding the e5
pawn still putting pressure on c3
and then white can just continue
developing castles queen f3 and so on
but this would have been best for black
however after this bishop the d3 move by
duba
we have rook to d8 by nakamura and again
it does make sense uh lining up the rook
with the queen here on d1
but uh there is a problem and here dubo
just castles he says okay
no problem there uh you're free to to do
something you can either continue
developing or start
start capturing some material and here
nakamura goes and knight captures on c3
he starts uh capturing on c3 but now
even though his queen is under attack
dubo does not recapture
he goes queen to h5 so already starting
with a piece sacrifice
and now asking nakamura what do you want
to do and it's not easy for example if
you just go back let's say an id5 and
you allow queen captures on h6
there is no defense against the bishop
to h7 is just game over if you dress i'm
like f5 then bishop e5 is coming and
that's uh that's just it so here after
queen to h5
we have bishop to f8 by nakamura
guarding that h6 pawn
but now comes rook captures on c3
and again what do you play here with
black uh
you have to play something your pieces
are still pretty much completely
undeveloped
uh here uh we have e5 challenging that
knight uh
also uh blocking the the dark square
bishop the queen guards the e5 pawn
but the double again says not a problem
bishop to c4
just uh going for that f7 pawn
threatening queen captures an f7 check
king h8 and queen to g8
checkmate so here nakamura goes back
queen to c7
guarding the df7 pawn but now the
position is completely lost so feel free
to pause the video here and win the game
for duba
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on deflecting the
queen from the defense of the f7 pawn
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's
bishop captures on e5 a lot of other
moves went to f4
f4 can win the game easily uh you could
go bishop back to b3
first open up a discovery on the queen
so all of this is possible
but bishop captures an e5 is the most
forcing and pretty much
forces an instant resign which nakamura
does so it was uh
in this position on move 17 that hikaru
nakamura resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done of
course if the bishop is captured you no
longer guard f7 so check
and mate will follow and if you try
something else
let's say after this bishop captures an
e5 not
not a lot of moves are possible here
like okay
captures uh is out of the question you
could try something like
queen to e7 just getting out of the way
but
then you allow queen to g6 because of
the pin here
uh and uh before this bishop captures an
e5
just to mention this is fine but it's
not anything special just bishop g7 and
now there is a threat of
f captures queen and the f7 pawn is
still nicely defended by the queen so
here
uh after this bishop captures an e5 we
might see something like this but then
it's again
check you your only option is to play
bishop here and now it is checkmate so
it is a bit different and uh lastly but
not leastly
after bishop captures an e5 you might
block with the bishop but now again
queen g6
check check okay now you do have the f8
square for the king but
then uh uh we have queen to g7 check
king eight
queen to g8 to check king the d7 queen
captures with check
bishop blocks and now of course you
don't capture the queen but rather
bishop the e6 and a beautiful
bishop checkmate so really amazing stuff
taking down nakamura
in 17 moves in game one with the white
pieces brilliant stuff
we'll see how how the match continues
and will nakamura be able to bounce back
and uh well uh do do something in this
match
so uh thank you for suggesting this game
i thoroughly enjoyed it i do hope you
you enjoyed it as well i will i would
like to thank uh
irish singh uh a mystery person andrew
darcy leslie and
liam vadmeyer for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the grand
final checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day